you know we often say when it comes to
Faith healing I'll be impressed when
they can actually regrow someone's
amputated limb of course it never
happens we now have a woman claiming
that indeed three amputated toes were
regrown now there's no evidence her toes
were amputated there's no evidence that
anything grew back they're not providing
any such evidence but here she is she
attends James River Church in Missouri
she claims prayer regrew three toes it's
a miracle so I had three toes that were
amputated in a terrible accident I heard
the word for Creative Miracles and I
thought well I certainly have a creative
miracle that I might need I need three
toes to grow back the person next to me
said do you want your toes and I was
like well sure all the women got down
and they prayed over my foot and I
decided to take my shoe off to see what
was happening when he said let's see the
progress or if a new things happened and
when I did I had to grab the person next
to me and say do you see what I see and
I saw three toes
that were forming and now there's length
to them tonight I can stand on my tippy
toes right so do you understand I can
stand on tippy toes no I couldn't do
that because I didn't have those boots
to be on
it's pretty remarkable stuff folks and
obviously they're presenting no evidence
whatsoever here's Pastor John Lindell of
the church who says he has the proof but
he's not going to share it with the
people demanding the proof because
they're not in favor of what he's doing
it's not up to him to validate this
stuff as you know there's been quite a
fewer uh I like that a few Roar on
social media relative to the girl with
the toes yep because her Miracle is real
it's genuine uh people are saying well
if it's genuine why aren't you why
aren't you doing anything with it to
publicize it there's a couple of reasons
I want to say to you first of all
um I'm less interested in improving to
people what I know God did than I am in
protecting sheep who are vulnerable
right now of course this is total BS and
this is where it really becomes BS he
says he's not interested in proving it
to people the whole point of view
Evangelical Christianity is to uh
proselytize it's to evangelize it's to
bring people in this is the greatest
thing they can do it's the greatest
Mitzvah and of course I'm using the term
Mitzvah tongue-in-cheek because these
they're Evangelical Christians so why
would I use the term Mitzvah I
understand it's the greatest thing you
can do the whole point of these
religions is to perpetuate themselves by
getting people to convert
what would more powerfully get people to
convert
than proving that you regrew three
amputated toes for comparison I I know
I've said explain this to people before
Jews which is the culture I'm from
Judaism there's no proselytizing but
we're not looking to add people to the
ranks even if someone wants to convert
their dissuaded multiple times and it's
a very difficult process so this is a
religion that is all about that their
main point is to spread the gospel and
he has the most powerful tool to do that
that prayer regrew the three toes of a
woman whose toes have been amputated but
he's not going to do it
he's not going to do it it's a missed
opportunity my friend obviously it is
complete and total nonsense we don't
even know whether This Woman's toes were
ever amputated there's no evidence they
grew back there's no evidence of
anything
but that is not a big shock to those of
us that have been following the faith
healing movement for a very long time